the face of colin kaepernick has come to
mean a lot more than sport and the words
on this new Nike ad go to the very heart
of his place in what's become a culture
war his kneeling during the national
anthem a protest at police brutality and
social injustice was embraced and
condemned so too Nikes decision has been
calls for a boycott and more drastic
direct action towards Nike goods but
there has also been support I mean if I
didn't love Nike enough they made Colin
Kapernick to face it I'd just do what
campaign for the 30th anniversary oh my
god and that a community store Nike
built in a troubled Los Angeles
neighborhood the Kaepernick campaign is
a popular one I'm all for him i'ma buy
more Nikes you know products now thanks
to him everybody has a right to their
own opinion so I mean if that's the way
he wanted to show it then that's the way
he did it so everybody has a right to
come off and prota that's what makes
this country great the person we haven't
heard from is the president Donald Trump
has repeatedly criticized players who
protest during the anthem wouldn't you
love to see one of these NFL owners when
somebody disrespects our flag to say get
that son of the field right now he's
fired that added fuel to an already
heated debate on race and inequality one
Nike has now waded into they've now put
themselves Nike the brand up against
America the brand an America the brand
is supposed to be about an identity for
all people irrespective of color creed
whatever it might be Colin Kaepernick is
actually suing the NFL right now
claiming it colluded to prevent him from
getting a contract with a new team it is
unlikely he'll ever play at that level
again but with the new season
approaching what he started is certain
to dominate way beyond the football
field nike share price has taken a hit
but this is a long-term bet they're
planning a range of Kaepernick
merchandise trainers and t-shirts
putting sport politics and activism that
culture war right on everyone's high
street Greg Milam Sky News Los Angeles